Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. At New Balance, we believe if you run, you're a runner, however you choose to do it. Because when you're not worried about doing things the right way, you're free to discover your way. And that's what running's all about. Run your way at newbalance.com slash running. This episode discusses the horrors of slavery in the Caribbean during the 18th century.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告版本、抢先体验节目系列并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在 New Balance，我们坚信只要你跑步，你就是一名跑者，无论你选择以何种方式奔跑。因为当你不再担心是否用正确的方式做事时，你就可以自由地探索属于你自己的方式。而这正是跑步的意义所在。访问 newbalance.com/running，开启属于你的奔跑方式。本集将讨论18世纪加勒比地区奴隶制的恐怖。
Some of the details are very graphic and may be upsetting, particularly for younger listeners. So please do be warned. Thank you. For want of dwelling near enough to the blessed truth, I was leavened too much into the nature of the people there, which are masters and mistresses of slaves. Though I never had nor would have any of my own, but by conversing, trading, and living daily amongst them, where there is vast numbers, abundance coming daily to buy goods and to beg, some to steal, we had abundance stolen from us at times, the worth of ten, fifteen, or near twenty shillings at a time, come into the shop, whole droves together, lay the scheme, I suppose, come
其中一些细节非常直观，可能会令人不安，尤其是对年轻听众而言。因此请注意警惕。谢谢。由于未能充分贴近受祝福的真理，我被那里的人们的本性过多地酵化了，他们是奴隶的主人和主妇。虽然我从未拥有过，也不愿拥有自己的奴隶，但通过与他们交谈、做生意以及日常生活中生活在一起，那里有庞大的人数，每天都有大量的人来买货、乞讨，有些人来偷窃，我们有时会有大量的货物被偷，价值十、十五或将近二十先令的东西一次次被偷进店里，整群人一起来，我想他们是事先计划好的，是
by appointment. When many had come in, they seemed in great haste. One would say, serve me, another, serve me, serve me, come sometimes by twilight, and within night, then was their time. So when we were in a hurry, one would run away with one thing, one with another, and so on. Very much we lost, to be sure. Sometimes I could catch them, and then I would give them stripes sometimes. But I have been sorry for it many times, and it does grieve me to this day, considering the extreme cruelty and misery they always live under. Oh, my heart has been pained within me many times, to and hear and now now now it is so so tom holland that very moving reading is from uh all slave keepers that keep the innocent in
按约定来的。当许多人进来时，他们显得非常匆忙。一个人会说，服务我，另一个人会说，服务我，服务我，有时在黄昏时分到来，并在夜幕降临前，那时正是他们的时间。因此，当我们手忙脚乱时，一个人会带着一件东西逃跑，另一个人带着另一件，以此类推。可以肯定的是，我们损失惨重。有时我能抓住他们，有时我会给他们几下鞭笞。但我为此感到后悔很多次，直到今天这仍然让我感到悲伤，考虑到他们日常生活中所承受的极端的残酷和苦难。哦，我的心曾多次为之痛苦，去聆听并现在——现在，现在就是这样，汤姆·霍兰德，那段非常感人的朗读摘自本杰明·莱所著的《所有蓄奴并使无辜者陷入
bondage apostates by benjamin lay which was printed in 1737 in philadelphia it was printed by i read from you in your notes none other than benjamin franklin it was and benjamin lay who is much less well known than benjamin franklin he is the subject of today's podcast and we are celebrating him aren't we tom a Tom? A man short in stature, but great in impact. And great in heart, I think. Great in heart. He was the world's first, or you're claiming he was the world's first abolitionist. I'm not actually claiming that.
奴役的背道者》，该书于1737年在费城印刷，是由——我在你的笔记中读到过——大名鼎鼎的本杰明·富兰克林印刷的。确实如此，而本杰明·莱不像本杰明·富兰克林那样广为人知，他正是今天播客的主角，我们在歌颂他，对吧，汤姆？汤姆？一个身材矮小，但影响巨大的人。我认为他有着伟大的心灵。有着伟大的心灵。他是世界上第一位，或者你声称他是世界上第一位废奴主义者。我其实并没有这样声称。
Going back from the title within three minutes of the podcast. Well, as regular listeners will know, you're a great one for the dramatic title that doesn't necessarily correspond to the theme. So Benjamin Lay, as you said, he is very, very short of stature. He was four feet, seven inches in height, according to one of his biographers. was also a hunchback when he grew older he had a kind of very long white beard so very striking appearance kind of very unusual appearance and as you say isn't really a kind of great name to play with um he he grew up in Essex um so initially your first attempt at reading that was in an Essex accent but it became Australian and Abandoned. You abandoned that. I kept thinking white stilettos, white stilettos and a white van, but it all fell apart. So he ended up traveling from Essex to Barbados in the Caribbean and then to Philadelphia and Pennsylvania in the 18th century. So he was born in 1681, died in 1759. And Tom, that reading, So you chose that reading.
播客开始不到三分钟就背离了标题。好吧，正如老听众所知，你很擅长弄一个不一定与主题相符的戏剧性标题。正如你所说，本杰明·莱身材非常非常矮小。根据他的一位传记作家的说法，他身高四英尺七英寸。随着年龄的增长，他还有点驼背，留着一种非常长的白胡须，所以外表非常引人注目，外表很不寻常。正如你所说，这并不是一个真正用来玩梗的好名字……他在埃塞克斯长大……所以你最初尝试朗读时用的是埃塞克斯口音，但后来变成了澳大利亚口音，然后又放弃了。你放弃了。我一直想到的是白色细高跟鞋、白色细高跟鞋和一辆白色货车，但这一切都泡汤了。所以他最终在18世纪从埃塞克斯来到了加勒比海的巴巴多斯，然后又来到了宾夕法尼亚州的费城。他生于1681年，卒于1759年。汤姆，那段朗读，那是你挑选的朗读。
I got about halfway through it and I thought, I have no idea what's happening in this reading. He's describing when he's in Barbados and he and his wife, who interestingly was also similarly about four foot high and also a hunchback. So what are the chances? I don't know whether they'd met on a dating app or who knows. They had moved to Barbados and they ran a business and starving slaves would come in and basically would shoplift. Right.
我读到大约一半的时候心想，我完全不知道这段朗读在讲什么。他在描述他在巴巴多斯时，他和他的妻子——有趣的是，他的妻子身高也差不多只有四英尺，而且也是个驼背。这概率有多大？我不知道他们是不是在约会软件上认识的，谁知道呢。他们搬到了巴巴多斯并经营着一家生意，饥饿的奴隶会进来，基本上就是顺手牵羊。对。
And Benjamin Lay is describing how they would do this and then how in his anger he would whip them. So he says- Give them stripes. He would give them stripes. And then how he became crippled with guilt by this and mortified by it. And he ends up deciding that slavery as an institution is wrong and arguing this very, very early on in what becomes the great kind of firestorm of abolitionism that sweeps the
本杰明·莱在描述他们是如何做到的，以及他在愤怒中是如何鞭打他们的。所以他说——给他们鞭笞。他会给他们鞭笞。然后他是如何为此感到深深的内疚并感到羞耻的。他最终断定奴隶制作为一种制度是错误的，并在18世纪席卷英美世界的废奴主义狂潮的早期，就非常非常早地提出了这一论点，这一浪潮最终迎来了英国的废奴主义，然后从长远来看，迎来了美国内战。所以，我的意思是，他并不是第一个废奴主义者。我们谈到了16世纪的拉斯卡萨斯，即巴托洛梅·德拉斯卡萨斯，他本质上是从人权的视角来思考这个世界的，这种观点认为每个人都是按上帝的形象平等创造的，因此拥有上帝赋予的权利，这成为了天主教教义的一个基本部分。他得出结论，奴隶制作为一种制度是错误的。17世纪末的英国也有新教徒得出了同样的结论。但本杰明·莱是一个非常引人注目的例子，我认为部分原因是因为他的外表非常引人注目，而且正如我们将看到的，我认为你完全可以合理地称他为第一个激进主义者，也许而不是第一个废奴主义者。
Anglo-American world in the 18th century, culminating in British abolitionism and then in the long run, the American Civil War. And so, I mean, he's not the first abolitionist. So we talked about Las Casas, Bartolome Las Casas in the 16th century, who essentially, because he's thinking of the world in terms of human rights, this idea that every human being is created equally in the image of God and therefore has God-given rights, which becomes a kind of fundamental part of Catholic doctrine. He comes to the conclusion that slavery as an institution is wrong. There are Protestants in late 17th century England who come to the same conclusion. But Benjamin Lay is a kind of very striking example, I think partly because his appearance is so striking, but also, as we will see, I think you might legitimately describe him as the first activist, perhaps, rather than the first abolitionist.
因为他通过一系列特技表演来阐述奴隶制是错误的，我认为人们会对这些把戏感到非常熟悉，就像现在“反抗灭绝”组织所搞的那些事情一样，诸如此类的事情。所以我认为他是一个非常迷人的例子。他将人们的注意力集中在我们在这期播客中曾经几度顺便探讨过的问题上，这些问题也经常在Discord上被提出，这本质上就是这样一个问题：如果废奴主义的传统是从一个特定的基督教背景中脱颖而出的——我认为绝对是这样——为什么它来得这么晚？为什么直到17世纪和18世纪才出现？基督徒是如何为拥有奴隶辩护的？以及为什么在17世纪和18世纪左右，某些基督徒开始认为整个奴隶制制度是错误的？
Because he makes the case that slavery is wrong with a series of stunts that I think will be very familiar to people from the kind of things that Extinction Rebellion are getting up to now and so on, things like that. So I think he's a really fascinating example. And he focuses attention on the questions that we have kind of discussed tangentially several times over the course of the podcast, and that has often been raised in the Discord, which essentially is the question of if the tradition of abolitionism is emerging from a specifically Christian context, which I think it absolutely is, why is it so late? So why is it not until the 17th and 18th century? How are Christians justifying having slaves? And how is it that around the 17th and 18th century, certain Christians are coming to think that the whole institution of slavery is wrong.
好吧。让我们从本杰明·莱本人开始，汤姆。他出生于1681年。正如人们如果只听了我最初开场的那段精彩口音就会猜到的一样，他来自科尔切斯特。在埃塞克斯，是的。在英格兰东南部的埃塞克斯。那么，跟我讲讲他的背景吧。他的父母是贵格会教徒。正如你所说，他出生于1681年。所以这绝对是在人们的亲身记忆之内，那是英国内战以及随后的共和时期（即克伦威尔统治时期）令人难以置信的大动荡。
Okay. Well, let's start with Benjamin Lay himself, Tom. So he is born in 1681. And as people would have guessed, if they'd only been treated to my original opening, in that excellent accent, he's from Colchester. In Essex, yeah. In Essex, in the southeast of England. So tell me a bit about his background. So his parents are Quakers. And he's born, as you said, in 1681. So that's absolutely within living memory, the incredible convulsions of the Civil War in England and the Republican period that had followed that, so the rule by Cromwell.
克伦威尔当政期间的一个标志是，对范围广泛的基督教教派保持着相对程度的宽容。这一时期涌现了大量的教派，比如狂热派（Ranters）、第五王国派以及所有这类——穆格尔顿派。穆格尔顿派。1650年代涌现的那个对后世影响最深远、至今依然活跃的教派就是贵格会。他们在1650年代的起源比后来变得更加激进，也更让同时代的人感到不安。从相对意义上讲，他们后来被驯化了。但在1650年代，他们明显是“世界颠倒”这种观念的一部分。他们甚至连名字“贵格会”（Quaker，意为发抖者）都暗示了这样一种感觉：他们在颤抖，他们在发抖，他们在怒吼，他们在
And one of the things that marks Cromwell's period in power is a relative degree of tolerance towards a wide range of Christian sects. And there are large numbers of these that emerge in this period, so the Ranters and the Fifth Monarchist Men and all that kind of- The Muggletonians. The Muggletonians. The sect that emerges in the 1650s that has the most enduring impact and that is still very much around today are the Quakers. And their origins are much more radical and unsettling for their contemporaries in the 1650s than they come to be. They come, kind of relatively speaking, to be tamed. But in the 1650s, they're recognisably part of this sense of the world turned upside down. And their very name, Quaker, it kind of alludes to this sense that they are shaking, that they're trembling, that they're bellowing, that they're
克伦威尔当政时期的标志之一，是对广大基督教教派保持了相对宽容的态度。这一时期涌现出大量的教派，比如兰特派、第五王国派以及诸如此类的……穆格莱顿派。穆格莱顿派。17世纪50年代涌现出的教派中，对后世影响最深远、至今依然广泛存在的当属贵格会。在17世纪50年代，他们的起源比后来的发展要激进而令同时代的人感到不安得多。相对而言，他们后来被“驯服”了。但在17世纪50年代，他们显然是这种“世界颠倒”观念的一部分。他们甚至连名字“贵格会”（意为颤抖者）都在暗示这种感觉：他们会颤抖、会战栗、会大喊大叫，会
kind of frothing at the mouth, that they're crying out at their meetings. And so it's a bit like the ranters. Yeah. The ranters have gone, but the Quakers survive. And the thing that's evident about the Quakers right from the beginning is that they reject kind of institutional frameworks. So priests, pastors, people who claim a particular authority over their flock yeah
在嘴里吐白沫，在聚会上放声大哭。所以这有点像兰特派。是的。兰特派已经消失了，但贵格会存活了下来。贵格会自创立之初就表现得非常明显的一点是，他们拒绝各种制度化的框架。所以牧师、神父，以及那些声称对信众拥有某种特殊权威的人，都是如此。
and so although it's associated with the name of george fox who is kind of traditionally named as the founder of the quakers that's not actually accurate basically there are lots of lots of people who kind of emerge at similar points similar places and they coalesce to form a kind of recognizable group of people. So these are people who, as it were, they're at the furthest possible extreme of the kind of the Puritan, I don't know, semi-Republican, radical, I suppose is the right word, the radical movement in the 1640s and 1650s that has flourished in the ruins of Charles I's kingdom.
因此，尽管它与乔治·福克斯的名字联系在一起，而传统上乔治·福克斯被尊为贵格会的创始人，但这其实并不准确。基本上，有许多许多人在相似的时间和相似的地点涌现出来，他们凝聚在一起，形成了一个可辨认的群体。所以这些人可以说是处在清教徒那种半共和的、激进的——激进或许是最好的词——1世纪40年代和50年代在查理一世王国的废墟中蓬勃发展的激进运动的最极端边界上。
Yeah. So they are at the radical edge of the radical Protestant Reformation. Yeah. And that their radicalism is expressed in various ways. So one of them, and I think in the context of our story, perhaps the most important, is the idea that there's a kind of the spirit is within them and that this spirit is a kind of fire. So there's an early Quaker called Robert Turner, and he says that the Lord moved his good spirit in me and his word came unto me, which was in me as a fire. So the Quakers have, obviously they have scripture, they have the Bible, but what matters is not just the objective reality of what's printed on the page, but the way
是的。所以他们处于激进新教改革的激进边缘。是的。他们的激进主义以各种方式表现出来。其中之一，我认为在我们故事的语境下也许是最重要的，就是这样一种观念：某种精神存在于他们体内，这种精神就像一团火。因此，早期有一位名叫罗伯特·特纳的贵格会信徒，他说主将他的善灵移入我体内，他的话语临到我，在我体内犹如烈火。因此，贵格会当然有经卷，有圣经，但重要的不仅是纸面上印刷内容的客观现实，还有那种方式
that you understand that with this kind of spirit within you, the fire of the Holy Spirit, enables you to penetrate to the kind of the hidden depths that otherwise would be hidden. And this is why Quakers boast that essentially Catholics, Anglicans, even Presbyterians have priests, they have elders, they have people in authority, but the Quakers don't have that. They're unmediated. Their relationship with the Bible is absolutely unmediated. It's one-to-one, and it's the feeling that is rising up within you that enables you to interpret it. There are other ways as well that will also be very influential on Benjamin Lay and his long-term campaign against slavery, which is that the Quakers are committed to a sense that all humans are absolutely equal, not just because
你用体内这种精神去理解它，圣灵之火能让你看透否则会被隐藏的幽深秘境。这就是为什么贵格会自诩天主教徒、圣公会甚至长老会都有神父、长老和掌权者，但贵格会没有。他们是直接的。他们与《圣经》的关系是绝对直接的。这是一对一的，是内心涌动的情感让你能够去解读它。还有其他方式也会对本杰明·莱及其长期反对奴役的运动产生深远影响，那就是贵格会坚信所有人在本质上都是完全平等的，这不仅是因为
they've been created equally in the image of God, but within the fabric of society, that no one person is better than the other. So they reject all titles. They reject any claim that men might have to a kind of superiority over women, so kind of a very radical sense of gender equality. They're very austere in their personal habits, which is a crucial part of what makes them influential almost immediately. People see them as kind of saintly figures. And they are very, very into expressing these views through a kind of activism. So the famous thing that they do is refuse to take their hats off. That is unbelievable.
他们在上帝的形象面前被创造为平等，而且在社会结构中，没有人比其他人更好。因此他们拒绝一切头衔。他们拒绝承认男性对女性拥有任何优越性，因此这是一种非常激进的性别平等观念。他们在个人习惯上非常简朴，这是他们几乎立即产生影响的关键部分。人们视他们为圣洁的人物。他们非常热衷于通过某种行动主义来表达这些观点。他们做的最著名的事情就是拒绝脱帽。这简直难以置信。
That's absolutely shameful behaviour, Tom. Shocking subversion of everything. Well, actually, you know what? I mean, we're joking about it, but if you're in the 1650s or the 1660s, not taking your hat off is a big deal, isn't it? It's shocking. Completely shocking. Yeah.
这绝对是无耻的行为，汤姆。对一切事物的令人震惊的颠覆。好吧，其实你知道吗？我的意思是，我们在开玩笑，但如果你生活在17世纪50年代或60年代，不脱帽子可是一件大事，不是吗？太令人震惊了。完全令人震惊。是的。
And Alec Ryrie, who's a brilliant historian of Protestantism, wrote a wonderful book about it. He tells a story of a servant girl called Elizabeth Andrews, who works in the house of Lord Newport. So he's not just her social superior, he's an aristocrat. And when she is serving guests at table, she refuses to curtsy to them and she the guests are kind of more amused by this i think than right an outrage i mean it's so shocking that they they can't even be offended by no clothes on or something yeah well we'll come to that in a minute but and they offer her 20 pounds to curtsy i mean that's a hell of a lot of money and she refuses and And she says,
亚历克·赖里是新教历史上一位杰出的历史学家，他曾就此写过一本精彩的书。他讲述了一个名叫伊丽莎白·安德鲁斯的侍女的故事，她在纽波特勋爵的府邸工作。所以他不仅是她的社会上级，还是个贵族。当她在餐桌上伺候客人时，她拒绝向他们行屈膝礼，而且客人似乎对此更多是觉得好笑，而不是感到被冒犯——我的意思是，这太令人震惊了，以至于他们甚至无法对此感到被冒犯，或者没穿衣服什么的。好吧，我们一会儿会谈到这一点。他们给她20英镑让她行个屈膝礼——我的意思是，那可是一大笔钱——但她拒绝了。她说，
I durst not do it for all honour belongeth to God. So she turns down 20 pounds, refuses to curtsy. Now you mentioned the nudity. Quakers in the 1650s are quite into nudity. You amaze me. And they're doing this, not like the Adamites, who are also part of the swirl of the religious times, who were doing it because they say, you know, you should try and get back to the primordial innocence before the fall. Quakers are doing this as a kind of activist stunt. So they are saying that they're doing it to highlight the way in which priests, prelates, Presbyterians are hypocrites, and that they are stripping off their clothes to kind of demonstrate the way in which priests, prelates, Presbyterians are hypocrites and that they are stripping off their clothes to kind of demonstrate the way in which They should be stripping off the priest's clothes
我不敢这样做，因为所有的荣耀都归于上帝。于是她拒绝了20英镑，拒绝行屈膝礼。现在你提到了裸体。17世纪50年代的贵格会信徒相当热衷于裸体。你真是让我大开眼界。他们这样做，不像亚当派那样——亚当派也是那个宗教狂热时代的产物，他们这样做是因为他们说，你知道的，你应该试图回到堕落前的原始纯真状态。贵格会信徒这样做是一种行动主义特技。所以他们说他们这样做是为了突显神职人员、高级神职人员和长老们的虚伪，他们脱掉衣服是为了展示这种方式，他们脱掉衣服是为了展示这种方式
really, I would have said. But anyway, there you go. Yeah. Well, but also it's targeting Cromwell. So there's a Quaker in 1654 who walks through the streets of Oxford absolutely naked and he's doing this to make a kind of visual prophecy that in time times very soon
实际上，我觉得他们本该脱掉牧师的衣服。不过不管怎样，就是这样。好吧，但这也是针对克伦威尔的。因此，在1654年，有一个贵格会信徒赤身裸体地走在牛津的街道上，他这样做是为了做出一种视觉上的预言：在不久的将来，
cromwell will be stripped of his that's all you know my views on oliver cromwell he is not a man i imagine that would in a million years walk through the streets of oxford naked is he no but he is quite tolerant of the quakers is he because he is because you know i said that there's a kind of a radical gender equality by the standards of the age. So women are as ready to preach this message as men. And one of them walks into his private quarters in Whitehall. Clothed or unclothed? Clothed.
克伦威尔将被剥夺他的……你知道我对奥利弗·克伦威尔的看法，他绝不是那种会在一百万年里赤身裸体走在牛津街头的人，对吧？不，但他对贵格会相当宽容，不是吗？因为，你知道的，我刚才说过，按那个时代的标准来看，这里有一种激进的性别平等。因此，女性和男性一样随时准备宣讲这个信息。其中一个女人走进了他在白厅的私人住所。穿着衣服还是没穿衣服？穿着衣服。
Right. But she sits down next to Cromwell. She kind of bursts into his bedroom, sits down next to him, calls him a dunghill, and then basically spends an hour haranguing him, urging him to become a Quaker. And Cromwell, to give him credit, I mean, he sits there and hears her out and then has her escorted very politely out. So there's no kind of comeback. And amazingly, there's another woman who's a former housemaid. She goes to America. So she's one of the very first Quakers to arrive in America. Yeah. And she's treated very, very badly by the Pilgrim Fathers out there.
对。但她在克伦威尔旁边坐了下来。她闯进他的卧室，在他旁边坐下，骂他是个粪堆，然后基本上花了一个小时滔滔不绝地训斥他，敦促他成为一名贵格会信徒。克伦威尔，平心而论，他坐在那里听完了她的训斥，然后让人非常礼貌地把她护送出去。所以没有什么报复。令人惊奇的是，还有另一个女人，她曾是一名女佣。她去了美洲。所以她是第一批抵达美洲的贵格会信徒之一。是的。她在那里受到了清教徒先父们的极坏对待。
So the Puritans in New England. She's whipped and then she's deported. So what she does is she goes back to Europe and she goes to meet the Sultan, the Ottoman Sultan. She meets him at Adrianople, Aden. I can't see the Ottomans caring for being addressed by naked people, calling them dunghills. Well, again, the Sultan, like Cromwell, is much more tolerant than the Puritans in New England. Hears her out and the woman says that he was very noble unto me. So there is, I think, a sense in which people are willing to, whether it's Cromwell or the Ottoman Sultan, are willing to, you know, these people are so extraordinary that they're
也就是新格兰的清教徒。她被鞭打，然后被驱逐出境。所以她做的是回到欧洲，去拜见苏丹，奥斯曼苏丹。她在阿德里安堡（阿德里安堡，亚丁）见到了他。我无法想象奥斯曼人会喜欢被赤身裸体的人搭话并称他们为粪堆。好吧，同样的，苏丹和克伦威尔一样，比新英格兰的清教徒宽容得多。听了她的诉说，那个女人说他对她非常高贵。因此，我认为有一种感觉，人们愿意——无论是克伦威尔还是奥斯曼苏丹——愿意，你知道的，这些人是如此非凡，以至于他们
almost, you know, they're almost kind of figures of fun perhaps. But so earnest, so brave, mixed in with that is a sense that they are to be respected but having said that quakers can go too far so the most notorious example of that is 1656 a quaker by the name of james naylor who gets so carried away with this sense that he's possessed by the spirit that he actually identifies with jesus and on Palm Sunday, he simulates Jesus's entry into Jerusalem with people laying down palms in front of him. He does it into Bristol. So casting Bristol as the new Jerusalem. And this goes down terribly badly. And although Cromwell doesn't approve of the fate that's visited on him, he suffers horribly. So he has a red hot iron, kind of goes
几乎，你知道的，几乎成了某种笑料。但又是如此真诚、如此勇敢，夹杂着一种应当受到尊重的感觉话虽如此，贵格会信徒也可能做得过火最臭名昭著的例子是1656年，一个名叫詹姆斯·内勒的贵格会信徒被这种被精神附体的感觉冲昏了头脑，以至于他真的把自己当成了耶稣，在棕枝主日，他模仿耶稣进入耶路撒冷，人们在他面前铺上棕榈枝。他进入了布里斯托尔。因此把布里斯托尔塑造成了新耶路撒冷。这引发了极其糟糕的后果。尽管克伦威尔不赞成降临在他身上的命运，但他还是遭受了可怕的折磨。所以他被用红热的铁块
through his tongue, leaves a hole in it. He has B branded on his forehead for blasphemer. He does two years hard labor. So the Quakers are kind of steering close to the wind and sometimes horrible things happen to them. But what happens in the wake of the restoration is that that kind of that spirit fire, if you want to put it like that, starts to fade. And so Benjamin Lay is born into a world where Quakers are a good deal less radical in their kind of public manifestations of the spirit than they had been. But the thing about Lay is that he kind of holds true to that primal sense of radicalism. Were his parents very keen?
穿过他的舌头，在上面留下了一个洞。他的额头上被烙上了代表亵渎者的字母“B”。他进行了两年的苦役。因此贵格会有点像在风口浪尖上航行，有时可怕的事情会降临到他们头上。但在王政复辟之后发生的事情是，那种精神之火——如果你想这么说的话——开始消退。因此，本杰明·莱出生在一个贵格会信徒在公众表现精神方面远不如过去激进的世界里。但关于莱的事情是，他依然忠于那种最初的激进主义精神。他的父母很热衷吗？
They were. And they seem to have been a direct influence on him so tell me you said he was short he's um four foot seven and he has a very large head and he's a hunchback and he stands in a peculiar manner is that right it's like what sounds like frankly a slightly camp manner yeah so a description of him that was written by um a man called roberts vokes writing in the early 19th century who was an abolitionist in philadelphia and a quaker yeah wrote a biography of benjamin lay that most of our information about him comes from and he says yes he was hunchbacked with a projecting chest below which his body became much contracted his legs were so slender as to appear almost unequal to the purpose of supporting him diminutive as his frame was in comparison with the ordinary size of the human stature
是的。他们似乎对他的影响非常深远，所以告诉我，你说他很矮，他身高四尺七寸，头非常大，是个驼背，站立的姿势很奇特，是这样吗？听起来坦率地说有点像那种略带戏剧化的姿态，对吧？对，罗伯特·沃克斯在19世纪初写的一段关于他的描述中，他是一位费城的废奴主义者，也是一名贵格会信徒，是的，他写了一本关于本杰明·莱的传记，我们关于他的大部分信息都来源于此，他说是的，他驼着背，胸部向前挺出，胸部以下身体明显收缩，他的双腿是那么纤细，看起来几乎无法支撑他的体重，尽管他的身材与普通人的身高相比十分矮小，
a habit he had contracted of standing in a twisted position with one hand resting upon his left hip, added to the effect produced by a large white beard that for many years had not been shaved, contributed to render his figure perfectly unique. Right. So a striking figure. And his parents are humble. So he's an autodidact. So he works variously as a shepherd, as a glover, works in agriculture, works as a sailor. And in the course of one of his voyages, he visits Syria. He could have met up with that Quaker woman who went to Constantinople. Well, it's a bit later. It's several decades after that.
他养成了一种扭曲身子站立的习惯，一只手搭在左臀上，再加上一把多年未刮过的大白胡子所产生的视觉效果，使得他的外表显得绝对独一无二。没错。所以是一个引人注目的人物。而且他的父母很卑微。所以他是自学成才的。因此他做过各种工作，如牧羊人、手套匠、从事农业、当过水手。在他的一次航海途中，他访问了叙利亚。他本可以去见见那个去君士坦丁堡的贵格会女人。嗯，那要晚一些。那是几十年之后的事了。
But all the time, as Quakers do, he is reading and reading and reading. And his sense that the spirit is on him is informing his reading. So he loves Milton. reading and reading and reading. And his sense that the spirit is on him is informing his reading. So he loves Milton. Typically, he said he represented George I with one of Milton's tracts. So obviously, the idea of presenting a king with Milton, who was a famous defender of regicide, is very Benjamin Lane. Also, a German king whose English is famously not very good. I mean, he's not going to be dipping into Milton. Right. So that's probably why he got away with it.
但贵格会信徒一直都在做的一件事就是不停地阅读、阅读、再阅读。他感到神灵附体，这指导着他的阅读。所以他热爱弥尔顿。不停地阅读、阅读、再阅读。他感到神灵附体，这指导着他的阅读。所以他热爱弥尔顿。通常，他说他曾用弥尔顿的一本小册子进献给乔治一世。很显然，向一个国王进献弥尔顿的作品——弥尔顿可是弑君者的著名辩护人——这非常符合本杰明·莱的作风。而且还是个英语出了名不怎么好的德国国王。我的意思是，他是不可能去翻阅弥尔顿的。没错。所以这大概就是他能蒙混过关的原因。
Yeah. Yeah. And Benjamin Lay feels that the Quakers, maybe 50 years after they'd first started appearing, are starting to become a bit Presbyterian, a bit Anglican in that they're starting to get a hierarchy of elders. Oh, they're selling out. They're kind of selling out. And he's very opposed to this. And he starts to disrupt Quaker meetings, objecting. And Vokes has this description of this. He says his temper was
是的。是的。本杰明·莱觉得，贵格会信徒在他们首次出现大约50年后，开始变得有点像长老会，有点像圣公会，因为他们开始有了长老等级制度。哦，他们背叛了。他们有点背叛了。他对此非常反对。他开始扰乱贵格会的聚会并表示反对。沃克斯对此有一段描述。他说他的脾气
violent, but it was always excited for mercy's sake and in behalf of those who dared not assert their own rights. So you can imagine he would be a nightmare on Twitter. Yeah. He'd be throwing cans of soup over paintings and stuff. All you can imagine he would be a nightmare on Twitter. Yeah. He'd be throwing cans of soup over paintings and stuff. All that kind of thing. Yeah. All that kind of thing. And basically the Quakers get fed up with him
暴躁，但它总是为了仁慈而被激发，为了那些不敢主张自己权利的人而发声。所以你可以想象他会在推特上成为一场噩梦。是的。他会把番茄汤罐头泼在画作上之类的。所有这类事情。是的。所有这类事情。基本上贵格会受够了他，
and he gets expelled from their kind of various meeting places. Right. And you might think that this would be terrible because he's now on his own and what's he going to do? Well, the answer is that he meets this woman called Sarah Smith, who, as I said, is also a dwarf, also a hunchback. And they get married
他被开除了他们各种聚会场所。没错。你可能会认为这太糟糕了，因为他现在孤身一人，他该怎么办呢？答案是，他遇到了这个名叫萨拉·史密斯的女人，正如我所说，她也是个侏儒，也是个驼背。他们结婚了，
and the pair are absolutely devoted over the course of their life. So she is the great rock in which he builds his life. And the pair of them set up as drapers in Colchester, but it doesn't seem to have gone well. And so they decide that they are
两人在他们的生命历程中绝对相爱。所以她是构建他生活的伟大基石。他们两个在科尔切斯特开了一家布店，但似乎进展并不顺利。所以他们决定
going to make a new life for themselves by going to Barbados. So they do this in 1731 to um make a new life for themselves by going to Barbados so they do this in 1731 that is a hell of a big leap it is Barbados yeah it absolutely is especially because by this point he's about 50 yeah so you know I mean that's quite a that's yeah quite a step to take so things must have been we can surmise from that that things probably went very badly for the you know the drapery trade in Essex in the 1720s for him to make such a radical break. Anyway, he goes to Barbados. Of course, he would know before he went there that there were lots of slaves in Barbados, wouldn't he? I mean, it wouldn't be.
去巴巴多斯开创他们的新生活。所以他们在1731年这样做是为了……去巴巴多斯开创他们的新生活。所以他们在1731年这样做，那可真是跨出了一大步啊。是巴巴多斯，确实如此，特别是考虑到这时候他已经大约50岁了，所以，你知道的，那真是一个相当大的跨度，相当大的一步。所以我们可以推测，17年代20年代埃塞克斯郡的布匹贸易对他的发展来说可能非常糟糕，才会让他做出如此激进的决裂。无论如何，他去了巴巴多斯。当然，在他去那里之前他就知道巴巴多斯有很多奴隶，对吧？我的意思是，那不是什么秘密。
That's not a secret. Of course, everybody knows that. So Barbados in the 18th century is about as close to hell on earth as you can imagine. And we think of it now as tropical paradise and all that kind of stuff. But by the 18th century, it's long since been stripped of all its native vegetation and it's been turned over to the growing of sugar. And the problem with this is that what you have with rotting sugar stalks, you have a great vat of water everywhere for the processing. And you have all the warm bodies of people who are laboring there. This is absolutely perfect breeding ground for the Egyptian mosquito that breeds yellow fever. So essentially to be on Barbados is kind of a death sentence.
那不是秘密。当然，人人都知道。因此，18世纪的巴巴多斯几乎可以说是你能想象到的世间人间地狱。我们现在认为它是热带天堂之类的地方。但到了18世纪，它早已被剥去了所有的本土植被，并被改造成了种植甘蔗的地方。这里的问题在于，烂掉的甘蔗茎到处都是，到处都有用于加工的大水缸。还有那些在那里劳作的人们温热的身体。这绝对是埃及伊蚊繁殖黄热病病毒的完美温床。所以基本上在巴巴多斯就相当于被判了死刑。
And so the corollary in turn of that is that people who go there and who work on it almost invariably die. And so how are people, how are plantation owners going to get the workforce that they need to produce the sugar that is the basis for all their wealth? And so as everyone knows, the solution to this is to start importing slaves from Africa. Yeah. So the Portuguese and the Spanish should use slaves on their sugar plantations in the late 15th, 30th, 16th century. And I guess by this point, it's just become completely globalized and industrialized, hasn't it, as a process? And I think Barbados is kind of, it's entirely given over to it. It's smaller, say, than Jamaica. And so therefore the concentration of suffering is all the greater. And basically by the time that Benjamin Lay goes there, there are about 9,000 Europeans, but there are 70,000 Africans who obviously are enslaved.
因此，与之相随的必然结果是，去那里并在那里工作的人几乎无一例外都会死掉。那么，种植园主如何才能获得他们生产作为其所有财富基础的蔗糖所需的劳动力呢？正如每个人都知道的，解决办法就是开始从非洲输入奴隶。是的。所以葡萄牙人和西班牙人在15、16世纪晚期就在他们的甘蔗种植园里使用奴隶。我想到了这个时候，作为一种过程，它已经完全全球化和工业化了，不是吗？我认为巴巴多斯差不多就是完全投身于此。它比牙买加要小，因此痛苦的集中度就更高。基本上，当本杰明·莱去那里时，大约有9000名欧洲人，但有70000名非洲人显然被奴役着。
And it takes Benjamin Lay a bit of time fully to appreciate what the implications of that are. I mean, initially, the thing that horrifies him is that a wild hog roots in his garden, and so he kills it. And the shame of this makes him a vegetarian. Yeah. So. Crikey. Yeah.
本杰明·莱花了一点时间才完全理解其中的含义。我的意思是，最初让他感到惊恐的是一只野猪在他的花园里拱土，于是他把它杀了。这种羞耻感使他成为了一名素食主义者。是的。天哪。是的。
So that's kind of the initial focus of his feeling of guilt. But then he cannot help but be aware of the suffering and the horror that underpins the wealth of this colony that he has come to to make money from. Because he's gone there to work as a merchant in the harbour or something, hasn't he? Yes. So the money that he is hoping to make ultimately derives from the suffering of the African slaves. I think it's important that people know what was going on in these plantations. So I don't want to shy away from the detail. But having said that, what I'm about to describe is, I mean, listeners should be warned. It is absolutely revolting. And so if you're of a
所以这是他内疚感的最初焦点。但随后他无法不注意到支撑着这个他来到这里赚钱的殖民地财富背后的痛苦和恐怖。因为他去那里是作为港口的商人或者别的什么工作，对吧？是的。所以他最终希望赚到的钱来自于非洲奴隶的痛苦。我认为人们了解这些种植园里发生的事情很重要。所以我不想回避细节。话虽如此，我接下来要描述的是——我的意思是，听众应该受到警告。这绝对令人作呕。所以如果你属于那种
disposition to find such things too upsetting, then please don't listen to it. And particularly if you have children, be warned. So I guess it will take up four minutes. So that warning given, here we go. So the only way that these 9,000 Europeans can keep order with many, many times their number as slaves is with spectacular displays of cruelty. And so they have to be public. This is the whole point. So slaves who are rebellious, who are infractious, who try and escape, they are executed not just publicly, but with the aim of inflicting as much pain on them as possible. As a deterrent. Yeah. Yeah. So they might have their limbs broken on a wheel. You know, that might take hours.
容易对这种事情感到过于不安的人，请不要听。特别是如果你有孩子，请注意警告。我想这需要四分钟。既然警告已经发出，那我们就开始吧。因此，这9000名欧洲人能够以远超他们数倍的奴隶数量维持秩序的唯一方法，就是进行极其壮观的残酷展示。所以这些展示必须是公开的。这就是关键所在。因此，那些叛逆的、不守规矩的、试图逃跑的奴隶，他们的处刑不仅是公开的，而且目的是尽可能多地给他们带来痛苦。作为一种震慑。是的。是的。所以他们的四肢可能会在轮子上被打断。你知道的，那可能需要几个小时。
Others might be very, very slowly roasted. Others might be put into a cage and hung in the marketplace, and they just slowly starve to death. The corpses of the dead slaves are then mutilated with the aim of encouraging slaves not to commit suicide, because the risk that slaves will commit suicide is absolutely an issue for slave owners. When a slave is sold, it has to be specified that they're not prone to committing suicide. Why would the mutilation of somebody's corpse after death deter them from committing suicide? Because the dream of many Africans who've been brought to the Caribbean is that after their
其他人可能会被非常非常缓慢地烤熟。其他人可能会被关进笼子里挂在集市上，让他们慢慢挨饿至死。死去的奴隶的尸体随后会被肢解，目的是鼓励奴隶不要自杀，因为奴隶自杀的风险对奴隶主来说绝对是个问题。当一个奴隶被出售时，必须明确说明他们没有自杀倾向。为什么死后对某人的尸体进行肢解会阻止他们自杀呢？因为许多被带到加勒比海的非洲人的梦想是，在他们
death, they will be able to return to Africa, their spirits. Whereas if they've been mutilated, they then can't go back. So this is the thinking of why the slave owners are doing it. And this has been going on for a long time. So as early as 1654, so that's during the Commonwealth period under Cromwell. There's a French priest who reports how an English slave owner in Barbados had whipped a slave until he was all covered in blood. And then this horrible detail that he cut off one of his ears, had it roasted and forced the slave to eat it. The degree of sadism and creativity, the creative sadism is so horrifying. And probably the most notorious articulation of this is not actually in Barbados, but in Jamaica. And it happened a generation after Benjamin Lay was in Barbados with a slave owner called Thomas Thistlewood, who's notorious. Yeah, very famous. So his notorious punishment is what he called Darby's dose. So Darby was a slave that he owned. And he wrote this journal and you can read it. On the 28th of January, 1756, Thistlewood wrote, had Darby well whipped and made Egypt, who was another slave, shit in his mouth.
死后，他们的灵魂能够返回非洲。然而，如果他们被肢解了，他们就无法回去了。这就是奴隶主这样做的原因。这种情况已经持续了很久。早在1654年，也就是克伦威尔统治时期的共和联邦时期。有一位法国神父报道说，巴巴多斯的一个英国奴隶主如何鞭打一个奴隶，直到他浑身是血。然后是一个可怕的细节：他割下了他的一只耳朵，把它烤熟并强迫奴隶吃掉。这种虐待狂和创造力的程度，这种创造性的虐待狂实在是太可怕了。可能对此最臭名昭著的表述其实不在巴巴多斯，而是在牙买加。它发生在本杰明·莱在巴巴多斯之后的一代人身上，有一个名叫托马斯·西斯尔伍德的奴隶主，他臭名昭著。是的，非常有名。所以他最臭名昭著的惩罚就是他所谓的“达比的剂量”。达比是他拥有的一個奴隶。他写了这本日志，你可以读到它。在1756年1月28日，西斯尔伍德写道，让达比狠狠地挨了鞭子，并让另一个奴隶埃及人在他嘴里拉屎。
This was because Darby had been stealing and eating sugar cane. A few months later, he's caught eating cane again. And Thistlewood records that he had Darby well flogged and pickled, then made Hector shit in his mouth. So pickled as they put vinegar on their wounds. Yeah. Awful. Yeah.
这是因为达比曾经偷吃甘蔗。几个月后，他再次被抓到偷吃甘蔗。塞瑟尔伍德记录说，他把达比狠狠鞭打并用盐水腌制伤口，然后让赫克托在他嘴里大便。用盐水腌制是因为他们在伤口上倒了醋。是的。太可怕了。是的。
And then unsurprisingly, Darby tries to run away, gets recaptured. So Thistle gave him a moderate whipping, pickled him well. So again, as you said, made Hector shit in his mouth, immediately put a gag whilst his mouth was full and made him wear it for four or five hours. So again, he kind of describes how slaves are hanged, ears are cropped, nostrils are slit, marks marks are put on both cheeks it just goes on and on and on um he just again there's um a slave runs away he's tried he's executed after which thistlewood gets the head back and in his own words put it upon a pole and stuck it up just at the angle of the road in the home pasture. So this basically is what leads the Marquis de Sade, who is a great connoisseur of cruelty and believes that moderns cannot rival the genius of the ancients, so the Persians and the Romans, for inflicting suffering and horror and torture on
毫不意外，达比随后试图逃跑，结果又被抓了回来。于是塞瑟尔给了他一顿适度的鞭笞，并同样用盐水腌制了他。正如你所说，再次让赫克托在他嘴里大便，趁他嘴里塞满东西时立刻塞上口塞，让他戴了四五个小时。接着他又描述了奴隶是如何被绞死、割耳、割鼻、两颊被烙印，简直没完没了……有一个奴隶逃跑后被审判处决，之后塞瑟尔伍德把他的头砍下来，用他自己的话说，把它插在杆子上，竖在家中牧场旁的路口。这基本上就是引导萨德侯爵的原因，他是一个精通虐待的鉴赏家，认为现代人无法在给人类施加痛苦、恐怖和折磨方面与古代人，即波斯人和罗马人相比。
people. But he says the only people in the modern world who can compare with the Persians or the Romans for their mastery of cruelty are the plantation owners in the English Caribbean. And so this is the world that Benjamin and Sarah Lay come to. Benjamin, a man so concerned about the sufferings of other creatures that, as I said, when he kills a pig, he's shamed into becoming a vegetarian. The impact on him of what he sees in Barbados will serve to change his life and perhaps you might say, you know, prove hugely influential on the course of abolitionism. I was about to say change the world, Tom, but your tabloid is slightly excessive. Yeah, right. Well, come back after the break and we'll continue with the story of Benjamin Lay. I'm Marina Hyde.
但他表示，现代世界中唯一能在掌握残忍方面与波斯人或罗马人相提并论的，就是英属加勒比地区的种植园主。这就是本杰明和萨拉·莱来到世界。本杰明是一个如此关切其他生物痛苦的人，以至于正如我所说，当他杀猪时，他感到羞愧并成了一个素食主义者。他在巴巴多斯所见所闻对他的影响将改变他的一生，或许可以说，对废奴运动的进程产生了巨大的影响。我本想说改变世界，汤姆，但你的夸张稍微有点过头了。是的，没错。好吧，休息片刻后我们再继续讲述本杰明·莱的故事。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. The poor blacks would come to our shop and store hunger-starved, almost ready to perish with hunger and sickness. Great numbers of them would come to trade with us, for they seemed to love and admire us, we being pretty much alike in stature and other ways. And my dear wife would often be giving them something for the mouth, which is very engaging.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。重复一遍，therestisentertainment.com。穷苦的黑人会来到我们的店铺，饿得奄奄一息，几乎因饥饿和疾病而丧命。他们中的许多人会来和我们做生意，因为他们似乎爱戴和崇拜我们，我们在身材和其他方面都非常相似。我亲爱的妻子经常给他们一些吃的，这非常吸引人。
You that read this may be sure in their deplorable condition. So that's Benjamin Lay, who we were talking about in the first half, remembering his shop in Barbados. So Tom, they've moved to Barbados, Benjamin and Sarah Lay. And I'm assuming that like probably a lot of people in Britain, they knew that obviously that there were slaves in the Caribbean, but the enormity of it, the horror of it was just a blank to them. They just didn't appreciate. And they get there and then they realize in their own words, they're in a place of barbarity and ill-got wealth. So do you think that dawns on them gradually, or do they realise basically not long after they've got off the boat? So Benjamin Lay, obviously initially, as was evidenced by the passage
读到这里的人可以确信他们处境悲惨。这就是我们在前半部分谈到的本杰明·莱，他在回忆自己在巴巴多斯的店铺。汤姆，他们搬到了巴巴多斯，本杰明和萨拉·莱。我猜，就像英国的很多人一样，他们显然知道加勒比海有奴隶，但其严重程度和恐怖程度对他们来说完全是一片空白。他们根本没有意识到。他们到了那里，然后用他们自己的话意识到，他们身处一个野蛮和不义之财的地方。所以你认为这是他们逐渐意识到的，还是他们下船后不久就意识到了？所以本杰明·莱，正如节目一开始你读到的段落所证明的那样
you read right at the start of the show, is kind of torn between indignation that slaves are coming in and shoplifting, which is why he uses the whip on them, and then is crippled with guilt about this, but also starts to realise that they're starving, which is why he and his wife start to give food where they can. And he has a very vivid description about throwing food for the slaves out into the streets. And he says, stinking as to be sure it was, yet the poor creatures would come running and tearing and rending one another
一开始在“奴隶来商店行窃（这也是他用鞭子抽打他们的原因）引起的愤怒”与“对此感到满怀负罪感”之间纠结，但也开始意识到他们正在挨饿，这就是为什么他和他的妻子开始尽力提供食物。他对把食物扔到街上给奴隶吃有着非常生动的描述。他说，虽然可以确定食物已经发臭了，但那些可怜的人还是会跑过来，互相撕扯争抢
to get apart in the scramble of that which I'm sure some dogs would not touch. So that obviously is a manifest. The fact that these slaves are starving is something that he's starting to become very upset by. But it's a few months before he sees for his own eyes the horrors that slave owners, among whom are Quakers, are perfectly capable of inflicting on their slaves. And so there's one particular day he goes to visit a fellow Quaker who owns a plantation outside Bridgetown, the main town in Barbados. And he and his wife, they walk up to the house and they find a naked African who is suspended outside their friend's house. And blood is dripping from the slave's body and it's formed a puddle in the dust.
在争抢那些我确信连狗都不会碰的东西时分。所以这显然是一个明证。这些奴隶正在挨饿这一事实，是他开始感到非常沮丧的原因。但就在几个月后，他亲眼目睹了奴隶主（其中包括贵格会教徒）对奴隶所能施加的种种可怕虐待。因此，有一天，他去拜访了一位住在布里奇敦（巴巴多斯主要城镇）郊外经营种植园的贵格会同道。他和妻子走到房子前，发现一个赤身裸体的非洲人被悬挂在他们朋友的房子外面。血正从那个奴隶的身体上往下滴，在灰尘中积成了一滩。
And obviously this has drawn flies. So they're swarming around the blood and they're swarming all over the slave's wounds. And the Leys are appalled by this and confront their friend. And the friend doesn't feel he has anything to be guilty about. He says the slave misbehaved. He's my property. He has to be punished. And it's this, I think, that sets Lay upon the path that leads him to think that it's not just that slaves should be well-treated, which I'm imagining was his previous position, but that slavery itself is utterly wrong. And that it's this that leads him in the long run to write tracts on which he's drawing on his memories of what he saw
很显然，这引来了苍蝇。它们在血泊周围嗡嗡盘旋，也在奴隶的伤口上到处乱飞。莱伊夫妇对此感到震惊，并去质问他们的朋友。但这位朋友觉得自己没有任何可内疚的。他说这个奴隶不守规矩。他是我的财产。他必须受到惩罚。我认为，正是这件事让莱伊走上了一条道路，使他开始认为，不仅仅是奴隶应该受到善待（我猜这是他先前的立场），而是奴隶制本身就是彻头彻尾的错误。正是这件事，最终促使他写下了那些汲取了他对当年所见所闻回忆的小册子
in Barbados. So he describes slavery as being a kind of lingering martyrdom that could last years and years and years. And the martyrdom, some above ground and some underground in caves and dens or mines, are murdered by working hard and starving, whipping, racking, hanging, burning, scalding, roasting, and other hellish torments very sorrowful to consider. And he says that everything that is produced by slave labor, of which sugar is the principal product, he says that it is irrevocably polluted, in his words, with grease, dirt, dung, and other filthiness, as it may be limbs, bowels, and excrements of the poor slaves. So that's a metaphorical. The sugar is, you know, you cannot put sugar into your tea
在巴巴多斯。因此，他将奴隶制描述为一种旷日持久的殉难，可以持续一年又一年。而这种殉难，有的是在地面上，有的则在地下洞穴、地窖或矿井里，他们因过度劳累和饥饿、鞭笞、刑具架、绞刑、火刑、烫伤、炙烤以及其他悲惨至极、令人不忍细想的地狱般折磨而被谋害。他说，奴隶劳动生产的一切（其中糖是主要产品），他认为都无可挽回地被污染了，用他的话说，沾满了 grease、污垢、粪便和其他污秽物，可能还有可怜的奴隶们的四肢、内脏和排泄物。所以这是一种隐喻。糖，你知道的，你不可能把糖放进茶里
and not taste the blood and sweat of the slaves who tended to the plantations, but also literally physical. So this is something that Marquis de Sade also picks up on in a tone very different to Benjamin Lay's. It has to be said that slaves will lose their limbs. You know, the grinding of the cogs and the machinery that crushes the sugar cane, they are endlessly losing their limbs. They're endlessly falling into the contraptions. Their body parts are literally part of the sugar.
却尝不出那些照料种植园的奴隶们的血水和汗水，同时这也是字面意义上的实体。所以这也是萨德侯爵所关注到的一点，其语气与本杰明·莱伊截然不同。必须说明的是，奴隶们会失去他们的肢体。你知道，压榨甘蔗的齿轮和机械的碾磨，使他们不断地失去肢体。他们不断地掉进机器里。他们的身体部位实际上成了糖的一部分。
And so Benjamin and Sarah Leigh turn abolitionists. And I think that the reason for this is partly the industrial scale of the horror that they're witnessing. It's this that makes them abolitionists, because Britain is starting to industrialise. And so the ability to inflict torments on slaves is greater than it's ever been before. Yeah. It's the scale of it. It's the industrial scale of it that is the horror. They can't dismiss it as a few bad eggs, a few sadists, because they know that it's an industry. But also, slaves have always been part of human history.
于是，本杰明和莎拉·莱伊成为了废奴主义者。我认为，这背后的部分原因在于他们所目睹的骇人听闻的工业化规模。正是这一点促使他们成为了废奴主义者，因为英国开始走向工业化。因此，对奴隶施加折磨的能力比以往任何时候都要强大。是的。就是这种规模。那种工业化规模的恐怖感。他们无法将其轻描淡写地归结为几个害群之马或几个虐待狂，因为他们知道这是一项产业。但同时，奴隶制一直是人类历史的一部分。
But what's different is that the institutionalization of it has never been on quite the scale before. So it's perhaps the difference between an abattoir in a farm and an industrial abattoir. You're more likely to become vegetarian if you go to an industrial abattoir than if you watch a butcher kind of kill a cow or something. Yeah, exactly. The other aspect of it is that slavery in the Caribbean is racialized. So that wasn't obviously the case even in the 1650s. Lots of white people are transported to the Caribbean, lots of Irish people particularly, but not Scots as well, and some English are taken to the Caribbean. But over the course of the decades that followed that, increasingly the workforce is
但不同的是，这种制度化从未达到过如此规模。这或许就像农场屠宰场与工业化屠宰场之间的区别。如果你去参观工业化屠宰场，你比看一个屠夫宰牛之类的更有可能成为素食主义者。是的，完全如此。另一个方面是，加勒比地区的奴隶制是被赋予了种族色彩的。在1650年代显然并非如此。大量白人被贩运到加勒比地区，尤其是大量爱尔兰人，当然也有苏格兰人，还有一些英国人被带到了加勒比地区。但在之后的几十年里，劳动力日益变成了
black. And that again is offensive to not just the Quakers, but essentially to Christian sensibilities. Because if there has been one core Christian doctrine, it's that all human beings are equally created in the image of God. And so that imposes quite a lot of strains on Christians who want to believe that black people are destined by their nature for servitude. And this is one of the things that over the course of the 18th century obviously feeds into Christian abolitionism. So not just for the Quakers, but evangelicals as well. Undoubtedly, this is something that the Lays feel very strongly. This horror at the industrial scale of slavery, the racialized
黑人。这不仅冒犯了贵格会教徒，从根本上讲，也触犯了基督教的道德底线。因为如果说有一个核心的基督教教义，那就是所有人类都是按照上帝的形象平等创造的。因此，这给那些想要相信黑人天生注定要受奴役的基督徒带来了巨大的心理压力。而这正是18世纪基督教废奴主义兴起的原因之一。不仅对贵格会教徒如此，对福音派教徒也是如此。毫无疑问，莱伊夫妇对此有着极其强烈的情感共鸣。这种对工业化规模奴隶制的恐惧，以及巴巴多斯奴隶制那种被赋予了种族色彩的
quality of slavery in Barbados is what enables the Lays to feel that the Spirit is illuminating their understanding when they read scripture and read there that God wants slavery abolished. Because notoriously, the Bible does not say that. At no point does the Bible ever condemn slavery as an institution. But the point is that Benjamin Lay's understanding of how the spirit manifests itself and how it enables people who have the spirit to understand scripture means that that isn't a problem. He can read scripture and absolutely feel that it is written there that God is against slavery. Because the fire that burns in him tells him that basically, the Holy Spirit or whatever. Yeah, absolutely. And so this by a few months
特质，使得莱伊夫妇感到，当他们阅读圣经并在其中读到上帝希望废奴时，圣经在照亮他们的理解。因为众所周知，圣经并没有这么说。圣经从未在任何地方谴责过奴隶制这种制度。但关键在于，本杰明·莱伊对于圣灵如何彰显自身、以及圣灵如何赋能那些拥有圣灵的人去理解圣经的这种理解，意味着这并不是个问题。他可以阅读圣经，并绝对坚信上面写着上帝反对奴隶制。因为在他心中燃烧的火焰告诉他，基本上，就是圣灵或者诸如此类的东西。是的，完全如此。因此，在他们抵达巴巴多斯后的几个月内，
after they've arrived in Barbados is what gives them the certitude that they must oppose slavery in Barbados. It reaches such a pitch that they end up being driven out of Barbados by the slave owners. Well, I was about to say, I mean, I'm guessing that they are not popular dinner guests, dinner party guests among the slave owners of Barbados. No. So they get driven out of Barbados and rather than go back to England, they decide to go to a city that has been founded by a Quaker. It's Philadelphia, the city of brotherly love. And they think, well, there, surely we will get a hearing. And they go there and they discover that in Philadelphia, as in Barbados, there are whips, there are chains, there are slave markets, and they're appalled by this.
这就赋予了他们一种笃信，即他们必须在巴巴多斯反对奴隶制。事情发展到如此激烈的程度，以至于他们最终被巴巴多斯的奴隶主驱逐出境。嗯，我正想说，我的意思是，我猜他们在巴巴多斯的奴隶主中间并不受欢迎，不是什么受欢迎的晚宴座上宾。是的。因此，他们被驱逐出巴巴多斯，与其返回英国，他们决定去一个由贵格会教徒建立的城市。那是费城，兄弟爱之城。他们想，好吧，在那里，我们肯定能得到倾听。等他们到了那里，却发现在费城，和在巴巴多斯一样，有皮鞭，有铁链，有奴隶市场，他们对此感到震惊。
Philadelphia, then of course, part of the British world. This is decades before the American Revolution. Absolutely. And they discover that, you know, there are lots of, obviously, there are lots of Quakers in Philadelphia. The Lays are appalled to discover that most of them think, again, that slavery is absolutely fine. And so they're so appalled by what they find in Philadelphia that they move to a nearby town called Abingdon, which is just outside Philadelphia. And there they launch themselves into a career of activism. So what they do, and this, I think, will seem incredibly modern. and perhaps we should bear in mind that basically people have not been doing this.
费城，当时当然是英国世界的一部分。这比美国独立战争还要早几十年。绝对是的。他们发现，你知道，那里有许多，很显然，费城有很多贵格会教徒。莱伊夫妇震惊地发现，他们大多数人同样认为奴隶制绝对没有问题。因此，他们对在费城所见的一切感到如此震惊，以至于他们搬到了费城郊外一个名为阿宾顿的附近城镇。在那里，他们投身于激进主义的生涯。所以他们做的事，我认为，这在当时显得不可思议的现代。也许我们应该记住，基本上人们以前并没有这样做过。
It's so common now. But what the Leys do is that they boycott anything that might have been procured at the cost of another creature's suffering. So they continue to be vegetarian. They make their own clothes. They drink nothing but water and milk. They live entirely on vegetables. They're basically vegan.
现在这太常见了。但莱伊夫妇所做的是，他们抵制任何可能是以牺牲另一个生物的痛苦为代价换来的东西。因此，他们继续吃素。他们自己做衣服。他们只喝水和牛奶。他们完全靠蔬菜维生。他们基本上就是素食主义者。
Right, crikey. In exactly the way that vegan activists today would boycott all kinds of things. In the 1730s, this is astoundingly radical. Yeah. Really, really radical. Then 1735, Sarah dies. So they've been there about four years. And with her death, it seems to have unleashed Benjamin. He becomes increasingly radical in his protests. And he is, you know, he's firing off the equivalent of blog posts, tweets, Facebook messages, all kinds of things. So endless tracks.
没错，天哪。就像今天的素食主义激进分子会抵制各种各样的事物一样。在1730年代，这可以说是惊人的激进。是的，真的非常激进。然后，在1735年，莎拉去世了。所以他们在那里大约呆了四年。随着她的去世，似乎彻底解开了本杰明身上的束缚。他在抗议活动中变得愈发激进。你知道，他就像在疯狂发布相当于博客文章、推特、脸书消息以及各种各样的东西。因此有写不完的小册子。
He produces one against products that are dependent on forced labor. So sugar, obviously, but tobacco as well and tea. So this would be very like people opposing. I mean, he wouldn't use an iPhone, for instance, because he would say that that's been produced by the result of slave labour, that the metals that have gone into it. He'd be very against anything that might be contaminated by Uyghur labour, anything like that. I'd be concerned, Tom, to be brutally honest, whether he'd be a listener to this podcast. Well, I hope he would. Maybe he'd be vain enough to listen to this. Let's be frank.
他写了一篇反对依赖强迫劳动的产品。当然有糖，还有烟草和茶。这非常类似于人们反对。我的意思是，比方说他不会使用iPhone，因为他会说那是奴隶劳动的产物，里面包含的金属是这样的。他会非常反对任何可能被维吾尔族劳动污染的东西，诸如此类。说句大实话，汤姆，我挺担心他会不会听这个播客。嗯，我希望他会。也许他会虚荣到愿意听这个吧。坦白讲。
He'd be listening for you and not for me. Probably. I mean, I can't, there's no way of escaping that. Well, so he's against capital punishment. Right. Well, I'm against capital punishment to be fair. Anyway, this isn't about me. It's about him.
他听也是为了你而不是为了我。可能吧。我的意思是，这无可回避。好吧，所以他是反对死刑的。没错。好吧，说实话我也反对死刑。不管怎样，这不是关于我的。这是关于他的。
And he's absolutely against slavery. So this is when he publishes All Slave Keepers That Keep the Innocent in Bondage Apostates that Benjamin Franklin publishes. Right. So that's what we began with. Yeah. So Benjamin Franklin is in Philadelphia. He's working as a publisher, close friend of Benjamin Lay, supporter. But even Franklin has slaves. And so Benjamin Lay has to kind of, you know... So he's holding his nose and working with Benjamin Franklin,
而且他绝对反对奴隶制。所以正是在这个时候，他出版了《所有把无辜者囚禁在奴役中的奴隶主都是叛教者》（All Slave Keepers That Keep the Innocent in Bondage Apostates），这本书是由本杰明·富兰克林出版的。没错，这就是我们开篇所提到的。是的。所以本杰明·富兰克林当时在费城。他是一名出版商，也是本杰明·莱伊的密友和支持者。但即使是富兰克林也拥有奴隶。因此本杰明·莱伊不得不，你知道……所以他是捏着鼻子跟本杰明·富兰克林合作的吗？
is he? Well, Franklin is a friend. Franklin is sympathetic. It would be like the protester, you know, the human rights activist who has an iPhone. You could be as progressive as you want, but it's very difficult, I guess, in today's economy to use things that are not in some way implicated in other people's suffering. I mean, that's the huge problem that Benjamin Lay is fighting. His take on this is much, much more radical than that of others. And he has to kind of draw people's attention to it because it's not obvious to people, even to people like Benjamin Franklin, even to Quakers. So this is why he starts adopting increasingly radical stunts. So as part of his campaign against tea trade, he takes a set of expensive china into the middle of Philadelphia and just
嗯，富兰克林是朋友。富兰克林是同情他们的。这就好比一个抗议者，你知道，一个拥有iPhone的人权活动家。你可以表现得多么进步都行，但在当今的经济体制下，要想使用那些在某种程度上没有牵涉到他人痛苦的东西，我想是非常困难的。我的意思是，这就是本杰明·莱伊正在与之抗争的巨大难题。他对这件事的看法比其他人要激进得多、深刻得多。他必须把人们的注意力吸引到这一点上，因为这并不为人们所显见，甚至对本杰明·富兰克林这样的人、对贵格会教徒来说也是如此。正因如此，他开始采取越来越激进的出格行为。作为他反对茶叶贸易运动的一部分，他带着一套昂贵的中国瓷器来到费城中心，然后直接
drops it, smashes it. And that china is, I mean, this is a big deal in the mid 18th century. Massive deal. Yes. Massive deal. In the dead of winter, he stands outside a Quaker meeting house with no coat, with one of his shoes off. And when passerbys come up and worry about the fact that he's going to get a cold, he says that slaves are made to work outdoors in winter dressed as he was. So that's why he's doing it. And I mean, very shockingly, he kidnaps the child of slave owners to show them how Africans felt when their relatives get abducted. That's a powerful gesture, but enormously risky.
把它扔掉、砸碎。而那套瓷器，我的意思是，在18世纪中期这是一件大事。大事。是的。大事。在数九寒冬，他穿着单衣、光着一只脚站在贵格会聚会所外面。当路人走过来担心他会着凉时，他说奴隶们冬天就是在室外做工，穿得也和他一样。这就是他这么做的原因。而且，极其令人震惊的是，他绑架了奴隶主的儿童，以此向他们展示非洲人在亲人被劫持时的感受。这是一个强有力的姿态，但风险极大。
Enormously risky, yeah. Does he not get punished for that? As in Essex, so in Pennsylvania, he's not popular with his fellow Quakers. I mean, this is the kind of things that do not make him popular. And his most spectacular stunt of all occurs at the annual assembly of the Philadelphia Friends. So he's left Philadelphia because he regards it as Babylon. But he comes back in for this in 1738.
风险极大，是的。难道他没有因此受到惩罚吗？正如在埃塞克斯一样，在宾夕法尼亚，他在其他贵格会教徒中也不受欢迎。我的意思是，正是这类事情让他很不受欢迎。而他所有出格行为中最轰动的一次，发生在费城公谊会（Philadelphia Friends）的年度大会上。当时他已经离开了费城，因为他视其为巴比伦。但在1738年，他又为了这件事回到了这里。
And he walks in, he rises to his feet, he smooths back his coat, he draws out a sword. You're not allowed to take a sword, obviously, into a meeting place. He's hidden it beneath his clothes. So it's a Quaker meeting place, yeah. So he draws out his sword. This is immediately shocking to all the Quakers who were pacifists. And he says that he is there to protest against the enslavement of Africans. And he says that the transportation and enslavement of people from Africa is as justifiable in the sight of the Almighty who beholds and respects all nations and colors of men with an equal regard, as if you should thrust a sword through their hearts, as I do this book. And he holds up a Bible and then he stabs the Bible
他走了进去，站起身来，抚平外套，拔出一把剑。显然，你是不被允许带剑进入聚会场所的。他是把它藏在衣服底下的。所以这是一个贵格会的聚会场所，是的。于是他拔出了剑。这立刻震惊了所有奉行和平主义的贵格会教徒。他说他是来抗议对非洲人的奴役的。他说，从非洲运送和奴役人口的行为，在全能者眼中——祂以同等的关注注视并尊重所有民族和不同肤色的人——其正当性，就如同你把剑刺入他们的心脏一样，正如我对这本书所做的那样。接着他举起一本圣经，然后用剑刺向圣经，
with his sword and blood comes spurting out from the Bible. Wow. I mean, a spectacular sight. And the blood turns out to be kind of juice, pokeberry juice. I have no idea what pokeberry juice looks like. They have very peculiar berries in America, don't they? Perhaps American listeners could describe it. But apparently it looks like blood.
圣经里顿时喷涌出了鲜血。哇。我的意思是，场面极其震撼。而那些血结果发现其实是一种果汁，美洲商陆的浆汁。我根本不知道美洲商陆的浆汁长什么样。他们在美洲有非常奇特的浆汁，不是吗？也许美国的听众可以描述一下。但显然它看起来就像血一样。
And he's cut out the middle of the Bible and put the juice in. And so it's kind of spectacular stunt. That is a tremendous stunt, I have to say. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, so this is very, very like people going to the meetings, the kind of public meetings of international institutions and staging protests. And again, the impact is all the greater for the fact that no one has ever done anything like this. So unsurprisingly, Benjamin Lay ends up so unpopular with so many influential Quakers that he leaves Abingdon and he goes and lives in a cave where he keeps goats, he farms fruit trees, he spins the flax that makes his own clothes. And in the cave, he stores his library,
他把圣经的中间挖空，把果汁放了进去。所以这是一种非常引人注目的特技行为。我必须说，这真是一个了不起的举动。是的。是的。我的意思是，这非常类似于人们去参加国际机构的会议、那种公开会议并策划抗议活动。同样，由于从来没有人做过类似的事情，这种冲击力就更大了不出所料，本杰明·莱伊最终在如此众多的有影响力的贵格会教徒中变得极不受欢迎，以至于他离开了阿宾顿，去到一个山洞里生活。在那里他养山羊，种果树，纺织用来做衣服的亚麻。在山洞里，他存放着他的藏书，
which is almost 200 books by this point. So he's still busy reading away. the flax that makes his own clothes. And in the cave, he stores his library, which is almost 200 books by this point. So he's still busy reading away. And oddly, having been such a controversial figure, having been treated as a kind of massive annoyance by so many people, as the decades pass, he gets older and older, frailer and frailer. He becomes more and more of a kind of living reproach to people. So Benjamin Franklin, he doesn't actually free his slaves, doesn't go that far, but he does draw up a will and it, by its terms, the slaves that he does own will be freed on his death. So there's that. Finally on his deathbed, this is 1759 by this point. So it's about 20 years after he'd done his stunt with the Bible and the pokeberry juice in Philadelphia. News comes to him from another of the annual assemblies of the
到那时已经有将近200本书了。所以他依然忙于孜孜不倦地阅读。说来也怪，作为一个如此具有争议的人物、一个被许多人视为巨大麻烦制造者的人，随着数十年的流逝，他越来越老，身体也越来越虚弱。他越来越像一面活生生的镜子，不断拷问着人们。因此，本杰明·富兰克林虽然实际上并没有解放他的奴隶，没有做到那一步，但他确实立下了一份遗嘱，按照其中的条款，他所拥有的奴隶在他死后将被获得自由。所以好歹有这么个结果。最后在临终前，此时已经是1759年了。也就是他在费城用圣经和商陆汁搞出那场轰动事件大约20年之后。费城公谊会的另一次年度大会传给他一个消息，
Philadelphia Friends that a vote has been held in it. And it has been agreed that any Quaker who not only owns, but trades in slaves is to be disciplined. So basically he's won. And he says, I can now die in peace. And he dies shortly afterwards. And it's an amazing story because although he's largely forgotten now, his example does, I think, clearly play a part in bringing the Quakers of Philadelphia around to opposition to slavery. And the Quakers in Philadelphia are so influential that they then start to have an impact on broader American society. And this, therefore, is part of what you might call the flame rush of the spirit through Anglo-American Protestantism that, by the early 19th century in Britain, ends up resulting in abolitionism. Yeah.
会上举行了一次投票。并且达成一致意见：任何不仅拥有奴隶而且从事奴隶贸易的贵格会教徒都将受到纪律处分。所以基本上他赢了。他说：“我现在可以安详地离去了。”不久之后他便去世了。这是一个了不起的故事，因为尽管他现在在很大程度上被遗忘了，但我认为，他的榜样显然在促使费城的贵格会教徒转向反对奴隶制方面发挥了作用。而且费城的贵格会教徒极具影响力，他们随后开始对更广泛的美国社会产生影响。因此，这可以被视为你所说的盎格鲁-撒克逊新教中圣灵烈火席卷的一部分，这种烈火到了19世纪初在英国最终导致了废奴主义的诞生。是的。
The abolition first of slavery and then of the slave trade. Because Leigh, when he was growing up, Tom, in the late 17th, early 18th century, this is in a world in which basically there's no organized abolitionist movement really, is there? I mean, there may be people who are opposed to slavery, but there aren't big campaigns in William III's England or something. No. I mean, it's a very, very, very eccentric position.
汤姆，莱伊在17世纪末18世纪初成长时，当时的世界基本上还没有真正有组织的废奴运动，对吧？我的意思是，可能有人反对奴隶制，但在威廉三世时期的英国并没有什么大型的政治运动。没有。我的意思是，这是一个非常非常极其偏激的立场。
So in the 1670s, there's a Quaker called William Edmondson who goes rather as Lay later does. He's gone to Barbados and being horrified by what he sees. He then goes to the New World and campaigns against institutional slavery. So Lay isn't actually, despite our title, the First Abolitionist. But what Lay does is to really, really kind of employ stunts, employ activism as a means for campaigning against it, and has this impact. And is he remembered by later anti-slavery activists, or did it take historians to kind of drag him out of obscurity, would you say? Well, so Robert Svokes, a Quaker who wrote the biography of him, does remember him. But no, I mean, the memory of him fades. A painting of him was found quite recently. So I'm sure both of us will put the picture of him. I have to say it's a pretty extraordinary painting, Tom. I mean. Yeah. I mean, he looks like something from a
所以在1670年代，有一个名叫威廉·埃德蒙森（William Edmondson）的贵格会教徒，他走了一条类似于莱伊后来所走的路。他去过巴巴多斯，被自己所见的一切震惊了。然后他去了新世界，并发起反对制度化奴隶制的运动。所以，尽管我们的标题这么叫，莱伊其实并不是“第一位废奴主义者”。但莱伊所做的是，真正以一种极具震撼力的出格行为、以激进主义作为反对它的手段，并产生了这样的影响。那么，后来的反奴隶制活动家还记得他吗？还是说，可以说是由历史学家把他在默默无闻中重新挖掘出来的？嗯，罗伯特·斯沃克斯（Robert Spokes），一位为他写传记的贵格会教徒，确实还记着他。但没有，关于他的记忆逐渐淡去了。不久前人们刚找到一幅他的肖像画。所以我想我们俩都会把他的照片放上去。我必须说，这是一幅相当非同寻常的画，汤姆。我的意思是。是的。我的意思是，他看起来像是格林童话插图里走出来的人物。但我认为出于显而易见的原因，人们现在对他更感兴趣，因为他似乎是过去几年中无论是“黑人的命也是命”还是“反抗灭绝”（Extinction Rebellion）等许多激进主义特质的先驱。我正在查看关于他的纪念碑。伦敦贵格会总部会所（Friends House）里有一个“本杰明·莱伊室”。在宾夕法尼亚历史博物馆委员会位于阿宾顿的墓地旁，有一个他的纪念标志，但那是直到2018年才设立的。是的。他本身就是一个迷人的人物，但显然，作为理解英国加勒比地区奴隶制的本质以及最终废除奴隶制原因的一个切入点，他非常有趣。而且要强调这种变革的过程是多么激进，因为我认为我们今天面临的问题是，我们太过于本杰明·莱伊的“后代”了。我们如此百分之百地接受他是对的。我们觉得他是对的这件事如此显而易见，以至于我们很难回溯去想象这样一个世界：在那里，基本上所有人都将奴隶制视为理所当然。不仅是欧洲人在买卖，非洲人也在贩卖，穆斯林也在买。我的意思是，这几乎是大西洋世界的一种普遍共识。奴隶制没有任何问题。正因如此，莱伊才显得如此英勇，如此激进。
kind of Brothers Grimm illustration. But I think people are more interested in him now for obvious reasons, because he does seem a kind of a forebear of a lot of the character of activism, both in terms of Black Lives Matter, but also Extinction Rebellion that's happened over the past few years. So I'm just looking at memorials to him. There's a Benjamin Lay room at the Friends House in London, which is the great Quaker headquarters. And there is a marker by his grave in Abington by the Pennsylvania Historical Museum Commission, but that was only put up in 2018. Yeah. He's a fascinating figure in himself, but obviously, I mean, he's interesting as a way into understanding both the nature of slavery in the British Caribbean and also the reason why in the long run it comes to be abolished. And just to emphasise how radical that process of change is, because I think the problem
72|||是的，我认为让他的故事如此引发共鸣、如此有趣的原因在于，我们经常很难理解17世纪左右究竟发生了什么，
for us today is that we are so much the children of Benjamin Lay. We so 100% accept that he's right. It seems so obvious to us that he's right, that it's hard for us to kind of think back into a world where basically everyone takes slavery for granted. And it's not just Europeans, it's Africans who are doing the selling. It's the Muslims who are buying them as well. I mean, this is pretty much a kind of universal assumption in the Atlantic world. There's no problem with slavery. And that is why Lay is such a heroic figure, such a radical figure. Yeah, I think what makes his story so resonant, what's so interesting is that so often we sort of struggle to comprehend what's going on in the 17th century or something,
我们今天的问题在于，我们深受伤害本杰明·莱思想的影响。我们百分之百地接受他是对的。他显然是正确的，这让我们很难回想起一个基本上所有人都把奴隶制视为理所当然的世界。不仅是欧洲人在卖奴隶，穆斯林也在买奴隶。我的意思是，这在大西洋世界几乎是一种普遍的共识。奴隶制没有任何问题。这就是为什么莱是一个如此英雄式的人物，一个如此激进的人物。是的，我认为他的故事之所以如此引发共鸣、如此有趣，是因为我们经常很难理解17世纪左右发生的事情
when let's say, you know, all these people at the court of Charles II or James II, they're all investing in slavery businesses. And so the temptation in the 21st century is to say, well, they must have been just wicked people, incredibly evil people. And it's sometimes hard to sort of explain that everybody did this. I mean, pretty much. Well, it's like people now investing in stocks and shares, you know, in any financial market. It's very difficult. All those people who listen to this podcast who have a pension, you know, do you know what your pensions, you know, is your pension invested in companies that in 300 years time, our descendants will find repellents.
比方说，你知道，查理二世或詹姆斯二世宫廷里的所有人，他们都在投资奴隶制生意。因此，21世纪的人很容易下结论说，他们一定都是些十恶不赦的坏人，极其邪恶的人。而且有时候很难去解释为什么所有人都在这么做。我的意思是，差不多所有人都是如此。嗯，这就像现在人们投资股票和证券一样，你知道，在任何金融市场里都是如此。这非常困难。所有收听这个播客、拥有养老金的人，你知道你们的养老金吗？你们的养老金是否投资了那些在300年后我们的后代会觉得令人作呕的公司？
And they'll say, how could they willfully blind themselves? You know, in the way that in the 18th century, an awful lot of people, well, the vast majority of people in Britain would almost have willfully not been interested in what was going on in Barbados or the Caribbean. They wouldn't have bothered to find out. Yeah. I mean, the thing that's so striking is Leigh's idea that it should be possible, in a sense, to kind of morally disinvest yourself from that. Yeah.
他们会说：“他们怎么能选择性地装瞎呢？”你知道，就像在18世纪，英国相当多的人——或者说绝大多数人——几乎是有意地对发生在巴巴多斯或加勒比地区的事情不感兴趣。他们懒得去弄明白。是的。我的意思是，最引人注目的是莱伊的观点，即从某种意义上说，你应该能够从道德上与那一切进行投资撤资。是的。
But he takes it to very radical extremes. I mean, he goes and lives in a cave and, you know, keeps a goat. I don't think many of us are going to do that. But I think what's the most powerful thing he did was actually that image of the sugar, that line that you had, Tom, well, you had, I mean, that he had about the sugar that is full of the grease, dirt, dung, and other filthinesses and maybe limbs, bowels, and excrements of the poor slaves.
但他将其推向了极其激进的极端。我的意思是，他去住山洞，你知道，还养山羊。我不认为我们当中有多少人会这样做。但我觉得他做过的最有力的事，其实就是关于糖的那个意象，汤姆，你刚才提到的那句话，哦不，是你说的，我的意思是，那是他说的关于糖的言论：糖里充满着油脂、污垢、粪便和其他污秽物，可能还有可怜的奴隶们的四肢、内脏和排泄物。
And that idea, I mean, because sugar is white, isn't it? There's a sort of image of purity of sugar. And the idea that it's stained not just with blood, but with the very bodies of the people who have suffered so dreadfully to make it. I mean, that must have been very powerful, and you would think incredibly shocking, to all these Jane know jane austen type people in britain who are kind of putting sugar in their tea or whatever yes and you know
而那个想法，我的意思是——因为糖是白色的，对吧？糖有一种纯洁的意象。而它不仅沾满了鲜血，还沾满了那些为了制造它而遭受如此悲惨痛苦的人们的血肉之躯。我的意思是，这一定非常有冲击力，而且你会觉得难以置信地震惊，对于英国所有这些简·奥斯汀式的人物来说，他们正把糖放进茶里或者诸如此类是的。而且你知道，
that dissenting tradition the um the methodists and so on who start to campaign against sugar who refuse to have sugar with it you know i mean that sense of kind of increasing boycotts is a ramification of that yeah go. Golly, quite a simultaneously horrifying and quite stirring episode of the rest of this history there, Tom. Yes. And I think we can save Benjamin Lay, a friend of the show, I think, Tom. Let's enroll him as a friend of the show.
那种异议传统，呃，卫理公会派等等，他们开始发起反对糖的运动，拒绝在茶里加糖，你知道我的意思——这种不断增加的抵制浪潮正是其中的一个延伸。是的，天哪，这真是一集既骇人听闻又相当激动人心的《历史余音》节目，汤姆。是的。而且我想我们可以把本杰明·莱伊尊为节目的老朋友了，汤姆。让我们将他纳为节目的老朋友吧。
Yeah. Thanks very much for listening. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
非常感谢收听，再见。再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。